do you think you helped normalize
anything
bad you know people have said that he
did lie a little more than most
presidents i mean no president is
completely truthful but let's
he's a bit of a fiber
i think the politicians exaggerate and
some lie but but didn't he do a lot
more than most but
didn't you once say i know you did you
once said he doesn't hurl personal
insults
i was making the point that when he
when he was in the context of something
and i also have seen him be very
uh very compassionate towards people
he's got people out of jail who were
languishing there
this is just a list of what he said
about me
oh a dummy dopey he's not a smart guy
dumbest man on television fired like a
dog needs to get back on the pot
dumb ass a rather dumb guy a lowlife
dumb as a rock [ __ ] stupid guy very
dumb guy
failing comedian a really dumb guy a
so-called comedian
third-rate comedian insane
sick wacko stole cold crazy and crazy i
can't imagine the applause is this
science i know but but come on he
you said he doesn't hurl insults that's
just gonna cherry pick things up
listen we've had listen i loved i loved
being in public service i loved serving
this country i loved i gave up millions
of dollars to go into the white house
and i loved what my portfolio included
which was healthcare education
the opioid crisis and i really liked the
the incoming that people asking
do you have information on this can you
help me steer this way i don't know what
i'm doing on this
there's a certain value to public
service and some people look the other
way
and you know i i would also tell you
just lumping together
74 million people with all the
troublemakers the thugs the marauders
that's my editorial but it's incredible
it's incredibly
it's it's it's incredibly dangerous too
and i know they vote every two to four
years but they consume products and
services every day
and i think that corporate america make
a big mistake trying to lump them all
together and just
and just ignore them i think that those
marauders and murderers i think that
they
insult not represent the whole the whole
trump movement and that 74 million is
not a base it's a large
percentage of this country but for me i
look at the good that was done to help
impact people's lives positively i think
that government is messy
i'm happy that i worked for a president
who
kept the oval office door open to many
of us we can go in and express ourselves
i didn't win every policy debate but i
was heard
and i think any woman in the workplace
who was heard by her boss
and has a seat at the table should
really appreciate that all these
corporate handbooks have it on page 684
we're going to have more women at the
seat of the table i had one
and like i said i lost some of those
policy debates i want some but he always
liked people to disagree in front of him
too but he is the president he
represents
the country when he was first there i
remember saying there was a book called
everything i need to know i learned in
kindergarten you remember that book i do
remember
it was probably when you were first
doing old politically incorrect shows we
were probably talking about
that tape and uh i wrote down some of
the things from it
as we look back on the trump years let's
see if any apply oh this is just
this is from everything i need to know i
learned in kindergarten
don't lie don't boast don't threaten
don't bully don't accuse people of stuff
that's not true
don't show off your wealth pay your
taxes serve your country
don't pretend you go to church if you
don't i don't care about that one
um don't be racist don't insult soldiers
try to learn something about a subject
before you
talk about it don't mock the handicap
and this one was not in the book but
don't grab women by the [ __ ]
that i i i think should have been i mean
when you see that does it
do you have any so you you think nothing
good came out of the last
i'm just thinking i'm just asking about
that you know the people who
the people who believed in donald trump
the forgotten man or forgotten woman
they appreciate an expansion of school
choice and charter schools why should
all
why should just the rich kids have all
the opportunities what i love about you
i read that list and you're right on to
charter schools no well
because it's important you're good at
what you do but listen this is but this
is what i do and i think it's important
to recognize you have
dead terrorists named solaimani you al
baghdadi
you have the whole judiciary the dead
terrorist you have
well but but that doesn't happen by
accident you know that happens when
somebody
i think obama got one too differently of
course he did not i don't know and i and
i applauded that
and i applauded that tremendously but i
i think that people
shouldn't be mocked for what they wear
how they eat
where they eat what they look like and
the trump people are constantly mocked
and
they felt like they had in donald trump
somebody who was giving them more voice
and visibility and
if you can match that with policy gains
where
you do have deregulation and taxes
lowered for people where it matters
other people will be just fine
okay and i and i think that that i think
his legacy
on the policy stuff will will survive a
lot of this last week was horrible
i made that i made that very clear last
week is inexcusable it's disgraceful
justice is being swiftly served you see
indictments already prosecutions there
should be punishment
and i think the fbi is is digging in a
little bit more into things that
maybe they knew ahead of time well happy
birthday happy birthday to you
good luck with whatever you do in the
future all right
thank you kellyanne conway
you